Дмитро Павличко  “Голоси мого життя”,
Дмитро Корчинський “Війна у натовпі”,
Володимир Василенко “Голодомор як злочин геноциду”…
Більшу частину вироку, який суддя зачитувала
дві з половиною години 5 червня,
склало перерахування назв книг українських авторів.
А також обставин, за яких вони потрапили до бібліотеки,
та висновків експертизи, яка визнала їх екстремістськими.
Російський суд вирішив, що директорка бібліотеки Наталя Шаріна
навмисне розповсюджувала усю цю  літературу,
чим розпалювала міжнаціональну ворожнечу,
а також займалася розтратою державних коштів,
винайнявши адвоката для захисту бібліотеки.
Вирок - чотири роки умовно.
З них рік та сім місяців, поки тривало слідство, Шаріна провела
під домашнім арештом.
На питання судді, чи зрозумілий їй вирок, Шаріна відповіла "ні".
Жодної книги ані в читальній залі,
ані на абонементі не було,
жодної книги, про які ви зараз говорите,
це Дмитро Корчинський.
По-перше, навіть якщо ми будемо говорити,
що вони були в бібліотеці,
вони були за межами абонемента чи читальної зали.
Далі, мені геть не зрозуміло, чому ми…
282-ї статті я взагалі не бачу.
Вирок суду та загалом кримінальну справу Шаріна вважає
політично мотивованими. А її адвокат вже заявив
про намір оскаржити рішення російського суду.
Хоч щось скажіть про умисел Шаріної.
Адже має бути доведений прямий умисел скоєння злочину,
передбаченого 282-ю статтею.
Але жодного слова
ані державний обвинувач не зміг сказати, ані суд.
Саме зберігання матеріалів,
нехай навіть з усіх страшних списків,
не утворює склад злочину,
для цього є адміністративна відповідальність.
Бібліотека української літератури до 2015 року
була місцем взаємодії культур.
В її фондах зберігалася сучасна література
з усього світу у перекладі на українську,
а також велика колекція старих книг,
зібраних філологами-україністами
ще на початку 20 століття.
Тут можна було записатися на курси української мови,
зустрітися з письменниками з Києва
і послухати старі грамофонні платівки з українськими піснями.
Нині бібліотека закрита,
а фонди передали до слов’янського відділу бібліотеки іноземної літератури.
Наталя Шаріна з Україною ніяк не пов’язана,
вона навіть не знає української мови.
До того, як очолити українську бібліотеку, вона працювала
у Всесоюзній книжковій палаті,
керувала бібліотечними фондами на Далекому Сході та в Москві.
ЇЇ трудовий стаж налічує понад 30 років.
Більше Шаріна у бібліотеках працювати не збирається –
за рік їй виповнюється 60 років,
вона йде на пенсію.